- This is the year that
you've gone back out.
'Cause you went off for
two like years, right?
- [Garth Brooks] Yeah. So we...
- 'Cause everybody did.
- We did the comeback tour '14 through '18
and then started the stadium tour in '19
and then the pandemic shut us down twice.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And people were very sweet,
but each time they came back
they came back in greater numbers
than they first were there so.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- It's so sweet.
I think what people love about
touring, that it's back now,
is I think people are
finally where they belong
and that's together again.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- So that makes me really happy.
- Exactly. And it's so healing.
So wait, so you and I have
done songs and stories before.
- [Brooks] Yes, ma'am.
- Which I loved and I heard
from fans, they loved it too.
So, it would be sad if we
didn't have a little like music.
Right? That would be weird, right?
(audience clapping)
Yeah, so I just thought we
just put this out there.
- Oh sweet.
Thank you very much.
- We'll just...
(audience cheers)
We'll just lay it there.
- [Brooks] Okay.
- And if the spirit moves you, fine.